- What's up Believe Nation?
My is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe,
and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the worlds major problems.
I started the Mentor Me series with a goal
to try to learn from people
who've done more than us,
and by hanging around
them a little bit longer,
hopefully some of their
mindsets, their attitudes,
their beliefs, their
confidence seep into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Joe Rogan,
and some of his best motivation.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as
you watch these clips,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in quotes
in the comments below.
You might win a prize, but
also if you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- You can get defined easily
by other people's perceptions of you.
My whole life I was convinced,
when I was a young man,
I was convinced I was a
loser, absolutely convinced.
Until I started getting
really good at martial arts,
I never thought I was good at anything.
I just had a very low self-esteem,
and I was limiting
myself by what I thought
were other people's opinions of me.
This is when I was a really young kid,
and I didn't figure this
out until I was in my 30's.
But I think that you
absolutely can be limited by
your perceptions of
someone's definitions of you.
But you can break through that stuff.
That's what you break
through with discipline,
that's where you break
through with hard work
and concentration and focus,
and that's why it's so important
to have either a discipline or an art
or something that you're trying to create
or something that you're
really focusing on,
cause if you don't have a
point of focus as a human,
I think it's very hard
to get through this life
and have an appreciation
for true struggle.
Because our physical struggle
with what our bodies are designed for,
the cavemen (bleep) 10,000 plus years ago,
our bodies are still designed for that.
That physical struggle
doesn't really manifest itself
when you're sitting in front of a cubicle,
you know, in front of a
computer in a cubicle,
in this unnatural position all day.
I think the whole
situation is very confusing
for the human body, and we
don't get the tests that we need
in order to have what you would
call personal sovereignty.
So you've got to impose
those tests on yourself.
Say if you had a kid,
obviously you do have a kid,
but say if you had a 20 year
old and he's just a doper,
where he wake and bakes,
doesn't get anything done,
he's just always hanging
out with this friends
and playing video games
and he's just a loser.
I wish there was a way you
could show someone like that,
I know that you're getting some comfort
and satisfaction out of just
laying around, doing nothing,
eating, getting fat, but
your life would feel better
and richer if you had a
goal, you chased that goal,
you accomplished some things,
you would get this boost of confidence,
you'd get this boost to self-esteem.
Like, whatever it is
that you're into doing.
Maybe you're into drawing comic books,
maybe you're into making
pottery or sculptures,
but find whatever the (censored) that is
and pursue that instead of doing nothing.
Like the people that are doing
nothing, those are the real,
look, doing something might be as simple
as that Alex Honald guy.
He just climbs rocks,
but he's a world class
rock climber.
- It's something though.
- It's something.
- I was always trying to learn,
I was always trying to figure
out what I was doing wrong
and what mistakes I was making,
because if you don't do that,
that's something I learned from jujitsu.
If you don't do that, then
you're going to get passed by
and other people are going to figure
some new way of doing it
and you're going to be left in the dark.
- Yeah, as much as I like to
use the term 'that was perfect'
there really is nothing
perfect in human beings.
There's always room for improvement,
there's always a shorter path,
there's always a quicker victory,
there's always new things to learn.
As soon as you start thinking
that you've mastered something
to the point of an end,
you've kind of missed
out what it's all about
in the first place.
You're constantly uncomfortable,
you're supposed to be
constantly uncomfortable,
and these little victories that you get,
the good thing about when people tap,
you get aaah, you get a little
nice feeling right here.
- Yeah, and then you're
like, let's go again.
- And then you're like, ah (censored),
back to being uncomfortable.
There's no getting, and then he taps you,
and you're like, ah (censored).
Should have quit while I was ahead.
No, no, because you're missing the point.
The point is that it's a long path,
a long arduous path, and I think
anything that's worth doing
is probably like that.
Yeah, right or wrong,
I'm real as I can be.
If I'm wrong, I'm sorry, I
didn't think I was wrong.
I'll tell you if I'm wrong,
but I'mma be as honest
about this whole thing
as I possibly can, and I
think we owe each other that,
and I think the idea that we don't
and that we shouldn't think that deeply,
or we shouldn't uncover
problems and issues
and we should just go about our lives,
ooh, I don't think that makes sense.
I don't think that makes
sense mathematically,
it doesn't make sense logically.
I think we, as a species,
owe it to ourselves
to be honest with ourselves.
That's the best benefit that we get
from being around other people,
is to understand the real
information as they see it,
and you can process that any way you like.
You can put it through the filter of ego
and personal circumstance
and all sorts of things
that make people have opinions
that are biased in one way or another,
whether it's liberal or republican,
but when you get past all that,
you really get to see
how a person is thinking
when they're honest.
And when they're not,
you don't really know
who you're talking to.
You're dealing in this
fantasy world of (bleep).
You're dealing in this world
where someone's pretending to be something
because it looks like that
looks best on the numbers.
You know, they've looked at some sheets
and say they prefer
Christian, nothing Mormon
or anything crazy like that,
that's what people prefer,
so let's go Christian.
They prefer a person that wears
a tie and a suit all the time
so let's dress in the appropriate manner,
and they sort of slowly but
surely segment themselves
into this ridiculous
population of pretenders.
I'm fascinated by martial arts.
I'm fascinated by comedy.
I'm fascinated by many,
many different things.
I don't understand when
people say they're bored,
because if I had the time
to live a hundred lives,
I'd be speaking different languages,
I'd be living in different countries,
I would try a number of different careers,
'cause I think there's a lot
of unbelievably fascinating,
puzzling, complex things that
you could study in this world.
But that's just me and my personality,
but that's the personality
also that I've cultivated
over years of challenges.
- Kind of like that
as a kid too.
- Well I was involve din
martial arts very early
and I think that is one of the things
that motivated me to
explore difficult tasks
because through difficult tasks
you learn an incredible
amount about yourself,
and through the fire of competition,
you get to understand motivation,
you get to understand the
resistance that you have
inside your mind to doing hard work,
you get to understand the
rewards of discipline.
You don't truly appreciate relaxation
unless you've worked hard,
and that is the yin and the yang of life.
I've said this to the point
of people getting sick of it,
but one of the worst
decisions a man can make,
I can only speak for men
obviously, is to be comfortable.
I don't think you should
try to be comfortable.
I think what you should try
to do is try to earn comfort,
and if you can get a day
off where you've worked hard
and you've accomplished goals,
that day off will be so sweet.
When I work hard and I
sit in front of the T.V.,
I enjoy the shit out of it.
I put my feet up, I have a nice drink,
I enjoy my free time.
- Do you have one of those
chairs that kneads your back
or something like that?
- I do have one of those.
- Do you really?
- Those are great.
I don't use it that much though, honestly.
I'm more of a workaholic
than I should be, probably.
I probably should relax more than I do,
but I never feel like I earned it.
But that's part of the reason why
when I do feel like I
earned it, I can enjoy it.
It's 'cause I am more
connected to the idea
that I need to accomplish things.
It's not for anybody else's
benefit other than my own,
or anybody else's approval
other than my own.
When I have a task, whether it's,
today I'm going to write
1000 words, or 2000,
or whatever the number is.
If I don't that, I write things down.
I'll write down a list of things
that I'll get accomplished that day,
and if I don't accomplish
that, I'll get sick.
I'll drive me (censored) crazy.
If I can't fill out that
list, that drives me nuts.
That's what led me to
be a championship level
martial artist, that's
what led me to achieve,
it's the reinforcement of those goals.
Understanding that you
can achieve those goals,
it's going to be difficult,
you're going to push
through the difficulty,
and then you're going to understand
what difficulty truly is,
and how much of it is just mental,
how much of it is just in your mind,
this adversity to a difficult
task or to struggle.
A lot of people have that, they're scared.
They're scared of complications,
they're scared of failure.
Failure's a big one that
people are afraid of.
But failure's one of the
most important things
you could ever have as
far as the motivation
to do things differently.
One of the reasons why
I think that I'm good
at friendships and relationships
is because I've failed at them in past.
One of the things that I'm good at comedy,
is because I've bombed on stage.
One of the reasons why I'm good at work
is because I've been a
(censored) worker in the past
and I know the feeling of failure,
the feeling of shame, of being a weak,
non-motivated, lazy person.
That's a weak feeling.
You don't respect yourself.
And I have this phrase that
I use all the time to people
to try to motivate people.
I say that, be the hero in your own movie.
Pretend that if your life was a movie
and your life started now,
what would the hero do?
What would the person that you respect do?
What would the person that you admire,
person that inspires
you, what would they do?
Well do that (censored),
and if you do that,
you slowly build momentum.
You're like, today I
did what I wanted to do.
Today I started a class
in yoga, I did this,
I did all these things that I
was saying I wasn't going to do
and now I feel momentum,
and momentum is a very important
point in people's lives.
That's why some folks
don't like to take days off
because they feel like
they're losing momentum,
and they sort of have to
restart the wheel up again
after a vacation.
When you're alone with your thoughts,
you get an idea of what
your thoughts actually are.
If you life your life
just acting constantly
on the momentum of other
people's expectations,
of you wanting to be liked
by these other people,
you can run into a trap,
and you set up a life
that you didn't really want.
You're trapped in this situation
where you have a mortgage,
you've got credit card
bills, you got student loans
you have to pay, you have a
bunch of (censored) going on
that you have to continue
to feed and all that,
and especially if you have a family
and you have to feed them, oh my goodness.
Then you're fully locked in.
You can't take any chances whatsoever.
An often-times people make
the mistake of getting stuck,
and it is just a tactical mistake,
just like it would be a
mistake if you got stuck
on a video game, just
like it would be a mistake
if you followed a map incorrectly
and you got stuck in the woods.
Your life is certainly
some sort of a journey.
It's certainly some sort of a journey,
and we have to all be aware
that when we're making journeys,
we're not going to always
make the right steps,
and sometimes you have
to back up and try again,
and if you're in a position
where you can't back up
and try again, you've trapped yourself,
and the system will set out honey pots
for people to get trapped in.
The system will set out
the ideas of retirement,
the ideas of the golden
years, providing you benefits,
providing you a healthy work environment.
Why?
Well because they want
people to work for them.
They don't want people to
realize their own dreams
and escape, well that's a pain in the ass,
you got to hire more
people and train them.
They want to set it up
so that you stick around.
You stick around in some sort
of an unsatisfying world.
It's up to you to see
that video game problem,
to see that issue as
it comes up on the map.
No, no, I think this is a right turn,
to see all the problems
that could potentially
lay in front of you, and
calculate your future.
And then also look around all the people
that didn't do it and look
at the misery they're in,
and learn that you don't
want to be like them.
And then look at the people
have kind of tooken chances
and navigated their way.
What did they do differently than you?
What objectivity do they
have that maybe you lack.
What insight into their own mistakes
are they willing to delve
into that you're not,
that you step back and you go,
I just don't want to look
at myself that closely.
But the person that's able to
look at themselves the closest
is going to get the more rational results.
And there's a lot of folks that live life
on a cushy cloud of
marshmallows and (censored),
and then one day something goes wrong,
and I mean, that's why
spoiled kids are so sad.
Like, a spoiled young boy is
one of the saddest things ever.
A young boy that becomes a man
and can't take care of himself,
and his dad has to keep on rescuing him,
his dad has to keep on
bailing him out of situations
and giving him money.
I've met guys like that, and
that is a crippling affliction
when they don't have
the character themselves
to be able to get by in life.
They constantly need someone to help them
and bail them out.
Even as a grown man, I've
met guys in their 40's
that still need help from their parents.
I'm like what the (censored) man?
You're never going to get it right
because somewhere along the line
they didn't face enough of the adversity
to realize that there's some
times we just have to get up
and get (censored) done.
There's some times where
you have to (censored)
pull yourself up and you
have to push forward,
even if you want to stay in bed.
And if you don't do that,
and you just keep calling on your Daddy,
and your Daddy keeps rescuing you,
you never develop those tools.
You never develop that
ability to recognize
what you're doing wrong with your life.
'Cause you're soft, you got a cushion,
you got a safety net, the
safety net for your safety net.
You know it sounds really hippy,
but true happiness comes from
making other people happy.
True happiness comes from
being around happy people
and enjoying each other's company.
That's really hard for people
to wrap their heads around,
because they always
associate true happiness,
no true happiness is
with titles, or numbers,
or objects that you possess.
You're not concerned about
being nice to people,
you're not concerned about
having a positive impact on people.
You're more concerned with
making ones and zeros.
That creates a negative
- And when you don't care
about other people, doesn't it really say
that you don't care about yourself?
- It does, and see we're not taught that.
It sounds like hippy (censored),
but it really truly is
how the human race
interacts with each other.
You really have to be nice
to other people to be happy.
You have to.
If you're not, you won't be happy.
We all make mistakes and
we all find ourselves
in positions of frustration
and we've all acted out, yelled at our dog
when maybe we shouldn't have.
There's pressures in this life.
But I think it's really
important to recognize
what those truly are,
and to understand that
at the end of it, we can alleviate a lot
of how we deal with this life,
if we really treated people
the way we would treat them,
as if they were ourselves
living another life.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What'd you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business?
Let me know down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to The Modeler,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and doing
that awesome review
on your Youtube channel.
I really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the read.
- [Narrator] Today we're going
to be reviewing the book,
Your One Word, by Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.